[Música]
en eeuu al menos 80 personas han sido
detenidas tras el asalto al capitolio
por parte de seguidores de extrema
derecha del presidente de donald trump
entretanto al menos 180 congresistas
anunciaron que ya tienen listo el
artículo para iniciar el juicio político
contra el mandatario saliente lo
presentarán ante la cámara de
representantes- el próximo lunes
tras ubicar los restos en el fondo del
mar en indonesia las autoridades avanzan
en la identificación de las víctimas del
siniestro del avión de lan olivia su
hija ya era el presidente de indonesia
yo he huido aseguró que se está haciendo
un esfuerzo grande por rescatar los
cuerpos y por establecer las causas del
accidente
y el mundo superó por primera vez los 15
mil muertos en un día por hobby 19
durante las últimas 24 horas el
continente africano superó también los 3
millones de contagios y américa registra
a más de 39 millones de positivos
también hay cifras récord en europa
donde avanzan las campañas de vacunación
regresamos con más información de
américa latina y del mundo aquí en fas
24 bienvenidos nuevamente mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en eeuu
porque cuatro días después del asalto al
capitolio de la nación más de 80
personas han sido arrestadas y cerca de
una docena enfrentan cargos federales
así que podría aumentar en los próximos
días dado que agentes del fbi avanzan
con las investigaciones tanto en redes
sociales como con vídeos y fotografías
con el rostro pintado sombrero de piel y
cuernos este hombre se ha convertido en
uno de los símbolos de los disturbios en
el capitolio estadounidense de 32 años
jake angeli se encuentra actualmente
bajo custodia por cargos que incluyen
entrada violenta y alteración del orden
público dos días antes del asalto así se
expresaba este seguidor ferviente de
donald trump
donald trump ganó la noche de las
elecciones lo que estamos presenciando
es una revelación real y completa de lo
corrupto crece el sistema se hace llamar
a sí mismo un chamán de la teoría
conspirativa cuya non de extrema derecha
que asegura que el presidente trump está
librando una guerra secreta contra los
pedófilos de la élite en el gobierno las
empresas y los medios de comunicación
otras decenas de personas también han
sido arrestadas en este contexto
incluyendo un hombre que fue filmado
liderando a un grupo en el interior del
capitolio por desoír órdenes policiales
enfrenta cargos federales de
allanamiento y alteración del orden y es
probable que detenciones y cargos
aumenten mientras los investigadores
buscan en las redes sociales para
identificar a los asaltantes
richard barnet de 60 años ha sido
inculpado a este individuo de arkansas
en lo capto sentado con los pies sobre
el escritorio de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
ella no está valorando el escritorio así
que pensé en sentarme y apreciarlo apoyó
los pies sobre el escritorio la policía
también ha arrestado a adam johnson el
hombre que fue fotografiado llevándose
el atril de pelos y según el fbi cientos
de sus agentes están buscando en todo el
país pistas para llevar a más atacantes
ante la justicia
entretanto el presidente saliente de
donald trump se enfrenta a un posible
juicio político al menos 180 integrantes
del congreso apoyan un artículo de
impeachment que presentarán ante la
cámara de representantes el próximo
lunes
el objetivo del texto es sacar a tron de
su cargo acusado de incitar a la
insurrección por los hechos del pasado
miércoles en washington
de esa manera de donald trump se
convertiría en el único presidente en la
historia del país en ser sometido a dos
juicios políticos sin embargo las
posibilidades de que la medida prospere
son pocas ya que cualquier impugnación
en la cámara baja- llevaría a un juicio
en el senado controlado todavía por los
republicanos
seguimos hablando de eeuu porque el país
anunció el fin de las restricciones auto
impuestas a los contactos entre
diplomáticos estadounidenses y sus
homólogos en taiwán
la medida fue anunciada por el
secretario de estado muy complejo y
amenaza con escalar las tensiones con el
gobierno de beijing sobre la política de
una sola china beijing ya advirtió a
washington que está jugando con fuego
taiwán tiene su propio gobierno pero la
república popular de china la considera
como una provincia una disputa de 70
años la mayoría de los países de la onu
no reconocen al gobierno de taipei pero
desde la llegada de donald trump al
poder eeuu ha intensificado su respaldo
hacia la isla
tanto taiwán como eeuu representan
valores comunes como la democracia la
libertad y tener una mentalidad abierta
interactuaremos más a menudo para el
beneficio mutuo además eeuu ha mostrado
su apoyo a taiwán partidos políticos en
el congreso estadounidense han apoyado
unánimamente varios proyectos de ley que
apoyan a taiwán en años anteriores bajo
el liderazgo del presidente de sai hemos
obtenido varias armas de defensa de
instalaciones que el país necesita de la
cambiamos de información y vamos a
indonesia donde las autoridades aún
avanzan en la recuperación e
identificación de cuerpos después de
confirmar que los restos encontrados en
altamar corresponden a los del avión
siniestrado ayer con 62 personas a bordo
la agencia de búsqueda y rescate de
indonesia informó que se habían
detectado señales de emergencia que
podrían corresponder a la caja negra de
la aeronave también se encontraron
restos frente a las costas de yakarta la
capital las autoridades confirmaron que
se está recolectando adn de los
familiares de las víctimas para poder
avanzar en las tareas de identificación
o para allá ya estamos haciendo todo lo
que podemos para encontrar y rescatar a
las víctimas
oremos juntos para que las víctimas
puedan ser halladas también le he pedido
a la comisión nacional de seguridad del
transporte que lleve a cabo un estudio
investigativo del desastre
tras examinar los restos entregados por
la marina hemos encontrado ropa de niños
rosa el resto será llevado a la comisión
de seguridad del transporte vamos ahora
con información del coi 19 porque la
pandemia deja cita récord durante la
última jornada el mundo superó por
primera vez los 15 mil muertos en un día
por la enfermedad y se acerca a los 2
millones de fallecidos veamos en nuestra
pantalla el continente africano superó
también los 3 millones de casos
confirmados y los 72 mil muertos
américa del sur tiene casi 14 millones
de contagios y más de 375.000 fallecidos
en norte y centroamérica registran más
de 25 millones de positivos por encima
de 542 mil muertos
y es que américa latina' también vive un
momento crítico de la pandemia con cifra
récord de contagios en países como
brasil colombia y méjico
la ocupación en unidades de cuidados
intensivos se acerca al 90 por ciento y
las autoridades implementan nuevas
restricciones sin embargo miles de
personas han viajado para disfrutar de
las playas y lugares públicos en el
último fin de semana de las vacaciones
de verano en argentina miles de personas
se congregaron en las playas de mar del
plata mientras en colombia las ciudades
más concurridas fueron cartagena y santa
marta en la costa caribe del país
por su parte europa también tiene una
situación que no mejora y varias
naciones se enfrentan repuntes en
contagios y hospitalizaciones esto
mientras los países del bloque redoblar
esfuerzos para avanzar con las campañas
de vacunación en reino unido-
autoridades de salud alertaron acerca de
la grave situación de los hospitales y
confirmaron que ya se ha vacunado a casi
dos millones de personas mientras se
trabaja en la construcción de un súper
centro de vacunación en londres la
capital alemán ya batió un nuevo récord
de muertes este sábado con 1.188 y
superó los 40 mil fallecidos en total y
la ciudad francesa de marsella se
impusieron dos horas más de toques de
queda debido a la presencia de la nueva
variante del virus por efectos un año y
todos coincidimos en que no era la
solución adecuada
quiero evidencia científica de que el
toque de queda la siss de la noche'
reduce más los contagios que el de las 8
de la noche mínimo en españa hasta ahora
se ha confirmado la muerte de cuatro
personas debido a la emergencia
ocasionada por la tormenta filomena que
ha paralizado el transporte ferroviario
aéreo y vehicular
meteorólogos advierten que seguirá
cayendo nieve durante los próximos días
y las temperaturas podrían descender al
menos 10 grados a menos 10 grados
centígrados efectivos de la unidad de
emergencia militar desplegaron sus
fuerzas en el aeropuerto de madrid- para
ayudar a despejar las vías mientras
cientos de pasajeros siguen varados
os realizan elecciones presidenciales en
la nación asiática de kirguistán en una
votación anticipada a causa del colapso
del gobierno anterior el candidato
nacionalista salir a paro es el más
opcionado según las encuestas después de
ocupar el cargo de manera interina en
octubre de 2020 cuando el gobierno del
entonces presidente son by jane beroff
fue derrocado otros dieciséis líderes
políticos se postularon para la
presidencia de la nación aliada de rusia
y también en caso de estas se realizan
elecciones parlamentarias durante esta
jornada se prevé que el partido del ex
presidente nursultán nazarbáyev que
gobernó por 30 años obtenga la mayoría
de los escaños
esto debido a que los cuatro principales
partidos de la oposición decidieron no
participar en los comicios el partido
socialdemócrata nacional es el principal
de la oposición y está llamando al
boicotear la votación por su parte el
partido demócrata también opositor no
logró inscribirse para participar en la
contienda
así finalizamos entre las 24 porque
ustedes pueden continuar con más en
nuestra página web de 24 punto com y por
supuesto aquí con nosotros quédense en
sus frases 24
[Música]